game would have ended in a draw here
instead we saw a draw in a crazier way
and okay they're off it's Armageddon it
is Armageddon and Magnus starts with 10
minutes on the clock alireza has seven
minutes and remember Magnus playing with
the white pieces is in a must win
situation the players will get a one
second move increment once they pass
move 41 and oh look at that Magnus three
on the board with a sense of humor
putting his Bishop on D3 for the second
time today in front of its own d-pawn
and now we know the inspiration behind
magnus's opening choice in the first
classical game he clearly prepared this
line against the Petrov and he thought
okay Bishop D3 there wasn't bad why not
play it against the Sicilian but this is
the Petrov there have been a trade of
e-pawns and it's just a question about
whether white is able to generate enough
activity with his extra move here in a
symmetrical position well this is not a
nice thing from Fairuza to play the
Petro which is so drawy sometimes and we
would wanted to see something G5 and
firework in this game also but it seems
like feroze is so happy to get away in
the classical game that he says okay Dro
brings me the Vic brings the victory in
Armageddon so let's be very solid
wow and black looks Rock Solid I'm
really surprised by magnus's opening
approach in a must-win situation uh
needing to win with white for the points
here because he's allowed some trades
already shout out to Eric Rosen in the
chat he says oh no Stafford Gambit
yeah no Stafford Gambit unfortunately at
this level not yet at least maybe in the
last round if Hikaru needs to beat
Fabiano for tournament Victory there we
will see an opening like that one but
okay what do you think Judith any
chances for white to create an advantage
well Magnus has to create something the
question is whether where is he going to
bring the bishop to develop is he going
to play B3 and Bishop B2 or Bishop to E3
or F4 later but for the moment he goes
Queen B3 attacking the B7 Pawn
seven swiftly defended Queen C8
yeah black is a bit cramped you've got
to say maybe D5 and Knight D4 is a very
typical way of continuing the fight and
it's on the void you call it Judith you
predict it and white tonight is going to
find a beautiful Outpost or beautiful
square at least on D4 gaining time in
the process
and you think Magnus will keep pieces on
oh wow he trades off creates a very
strong deep on here for himself makes a
lot of sense because now if white is
reaching C5 and Rook c1o D1 white has a
very nice position so this is why Knight
D7 immediately trying to block the
opportunity for white to go C5
yeah black snow wants to come around to
C5 itself and hit this White Queen
and yeah both players playing extremely
fast up to this point Magnus has
maintained his time Advantage three
extra minutes I think rookie one is a
sensible move
but he goes Rook C1 and after Knight C5
I believe he wants to bring back the
queen to D1 and later play B4
it makes a lot of sense there's so many
ways that Magnus can expand with his
pawns and uh Ali was actually playing B6
yeah weakening some squares but at least
holding up the advance of White's Queen
side majority there is going to be
extremely difficult for Magnus to get
that C5 break in a bit later he's gonna
have to regroup his pieces it's going to
take a slower Pace now the game okay
first he jumps magnificent assists I
want to play C5 you're not going to stop
that
and I like the way alireza discuss you
be my guest I'm waiting for that
and here it is on the board
wow I've got to say I'm surprised Magnus
just going Route One super direct here
with C5 this is going to lead to a bunch
of Peace trades but he's arguing that uh
with his extra deep Pawn here in the
center he's cramping down uh Black's
position and black has some isolated
pawns on the queen side well right now
it's not so easy there but he's going to
be moving his Queen because the B2 Pawn
has to be defended so Queen A3 seems to
be the best move for that but you don't
want to enter into the pin right
Queen A3 you walk into that pin and it
might take a while to break that tension
so what to do if you step across to the
C file then after a bunch of exchanges a
bunch of trades on C5 the black Rook is
simply going to gobble up that pawn of
B2 but after all maybe it is possible to
go Queen to C3 let's say and if
everything is exchanged on C5 and Rook
captures the B2 D6 might be the move and
the great
counter-attack Magnus does not move his
Queen out of the eye line of the Black
Brook instead Bishop A6 hitting the
black queen
chaos for the first time in this game
wow
clever move creative move it is very
clever but I'm guessing that farugia
obviously can't touch the White Queen
has to just move his Queen anywhere that
protects the Knight on D7
yeah and the question is here if firstly
you can move the queen as you say uh
Ivanka can we take this Knight off the
board because it protects the white
Bishop who protects the White Queen and
from there the Knight is jumping to take
the White Queen there's a lot of
calculation to be done suddenly
yes which is usually something that you
don't have time for in Armageddon but he
must really eight because
he wants to keep the Queens on the board
Knight B7 I would think and uh you can
see that move did not meet with the
computer's approval it's been awarded
a question mark a 1976 there and look at
the A7 weakness exactly oh that pawn
keeps dropping off in every game every
day we see Bishop takes A7 somehow
happened Hikaru played it in his game uh
I think we've seen it in various stages
and wow big threat as you say to it
not easy to deal with white pieces look
clumsy this is a pin a self-imposed pin
but for now white has full control
serious problems are opposed to alireza
I think right now
we should mention Magnus is on five out
of five in his Armageddon he's won every
single one so far in this tournament
could it be six in a row
You Can't Win In classical but
Armageddon nothing uh no one can stop
him nothing going wrong there well
actually these days he's more happy to
play short and in time controls it seems
and he also expresses this View and well
the result here shows reflects that
quite a bit
wow he's really invading the black Camp
the black territory here Rook C6 look at
that Bishop Knight Rook for white just
entrenched in the black queen side and
not easy for furusia to deal with this
Knight takes Bishop the White Knight
taking the black dark Square Bishop
maybe a threat to win a pawn
yeah to God after God against that one
fruit is all tied up yeah it's not so
easy to look for counter chances for
black queen E7 may be protecting the D6
Bishop but also after that it seems like
white can probably take on D6 and then
grab the B6 Knight and it's going to
cost a pawn for black yeah I wonder
whether there are also options of maybe
retreating the bishop all the way back
to C8 just to ask some questions to the
night and hopefully Bank on some
activity after that I think white should
be capturing the Knight first on B6 and
only after that to capture the D6 then
black still is losing material
yeah black is likely going to lose a
pawn no matter what so farisha just has
to find a version in which he's active
in which he can throw questions to
Magnus clock times not in his favor down
under three minutes now still a long
long time before he gets that valuable
Priceless one second increment
it's going to be a struggle to even get
there at this point and he Retreats the
Knight back to C8 with the idea of
capturing
and still his well farisha's pawns are
just a disaster there on the queen side
but perhaps furuji can generate some
play on the king side once uh White
moves the Queen White has the Beloved
Bishop here it feels like if Magnus can
weather the storm and not allow any
counter play those white Bishops are
going to clean up just need to move the
queen first attacked by the Black Brook
yeah this is the question where white is
moving the queen I think in the next
move somehow black wants to go Bishop to
E4 in the center and attack probably the
D5 Pawn because for now the G2 pressure
is not much but I can imagine I can
imagine that black goes Bishop E4 F5
Queen G6 and looking for counter chances
okay and Magnus slides over to C3 very
safe Square you'll move on the board you
that he needs some counter play and he
survived the worst position than this
already today for Russia so he will be
feeling optimistic if he can whip up
some activity
what's Magnus gonna do okay you're on A7
I can take this Pawn he can take the
pawn on C7 he has done
look C7 first
now the black queen has Avenues in
between A4 you want to say yeah first
move that comes to mind and he plays it
activity over everything here
hitting the white light Square Bishop at
the same time Bishop can come back to F1
where it's extremely safe and defends
everything the back Rank and the G2
Square
played and the food it is played but the
A2 Pawn is dropping but there is an E5
Pawn can drop and then an A7 and there
are quite a we're gonna see that because
that's exactly what's happened in the
game and the problem is for black if
Queen D5 takes takes then Rook D7 and
the piece is going to be falling off for
firoza
you cannot take that white Pawn on D5
you lose a piece you get skewered at the
end there and farusha shaking his head
for the first time in this game but how
does he maintain the piece I don't think
he can I think he's missed this I think
he was banking on the fact that he
played Queen takes Pawn but this will
not work and while farisa stops the
clock and resigns
yeah Magnus once again takes an
Armageddon victory